royang a back-to-back victories if I'm
not mistaken but this one must feel
quite nice is this the first time that
you're defeating Carissa in I think so
wow amazing game and this is where all
her troubles started after this move
Knight to F4 tell us a bit about your
reaction so
I I
can't be that
because like takes takes an ID for her
A7 Bishop is locked out yes
so I thought it said that at four she
was gonna play Queen F6 but like
um I said
Queen F6 and Knight E3 and I was I mean
I wasn't sure but I feel like I I was
probably fine here yeah
and this is some sort of yeah Theory
well I don't actually know how to play
this but Knight to effort definitely a
novelty and yeah not a good one yeah
and he took advantage just yeah because
because like my main uh my main plan
here was just to like trap her A7 Bishop
there so I played like B4 to software
from playing C5 which I probably didn't
need to but no no that was but I I think
also from a practical perspective you
must have felt her struggle to get that
Bishop out you know we were really
trying to find good squares for her
pieces but just simply not being able to
do so what was your plan at this point
because you we saw you playing this move
Knight to H2 we assumed that maybe
you're going for the killing I always my
main point was just try to take the F4
Pawn but um I I was thinking of Queen D2
but then like maybe like F5
F5 and I wasn't sure like because I have
to take thank you yeah like there's some
G5 stuff I mean I think I was better but
like I didn't want to like Risk this
like it's like Rook F6 and then I'll
probably not allow her to actually yeah
because her Bishop asked for the bishop
right very nice very nice and he decided
to play this move Bishop Knight to G4
yeah so like I'm like throwing like
Queen D3 and like take advantage of it
F6 squares so I think she has to take
is just
now uh the conversion was Flawless after
that the big victory for you Haru Yang
congratulations uh guys any questions
for ruyang she's warming up
uh yeah I I did
you're playing against Carissa as you
just mentioned she's been a difficult
opponent for you in the past how did you
approach a game where you're up against
an opponent who who's who's difficult
for you to play against what was your
mindset
I think I was like before the round like
I didn't really do any prep like
like I just like try to like play like
really like
um structures that I kind of have a good
feeling about like and just you know
just play the game and
just like relax before the grounds in
yeah get a position you want it's a good
preparation just to make sure you can
relax exactly play your own structure
well our congratulations very very
important victory for you young lady and
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you all right very nice